on a windswept hillside in eastern
ukraine yet another funeral in yet
another graveyard
this time it is a police officer shot in
the face by a suspected russian saboteur
close to the donbass front line
ivan savchenko is the seventh policeman
killed in his region
it is a scene that plays out here with
depressing regularity
but to each and every family plunged
into grief across this country
there is of course nothing routine about
bereavement
nothing at all
[Music]
we were invited to film this funeral by
a chief of police in donbass who was
anxious to show the world the toll this
war is taking on his men and women
it
is very important that people of europe
england friends and other countries know
about very dangerous job in our region
in this real time
but he knows putin is pledging to
intensify the war in this area of
ukraine
it will mean many more deaths many more
funerals and many more families whose
lives have been shattered on the whim of
a leader intent on so much destruction